hundreds of schools across the country
have had to close buildings of a dodgy
concrete has left them in danger of
collapse it's become a full-blown crisis
for the government and an early
Christmas present for fans of lazy
metaphors critics say this government's
crumbling before our eyes the walls are
falling in after 13 years of Tory rule
they failed to fix the roof while the
Sun was shining we don't yet know why it
took so long as a government to act we
don't yet know how long it will take to
fix it we don't yet know how much that
will cost but what we do know is that
absolutely nobody is to blame his prime
minister Rishi sunak accused of cutting
School budgets when he was Chancellor
are you to blame for what's happening
now do you want to apologize to parents
I think that is completely and utterly
wrong
says the Prime Minister Jillian Keegan
Secretary of State for Education First
said it was quote not her responsibility
before blowing up in this hot mic to
raid
but you're saying that the government is
not responsible ultimately for the
safety of children in school the the
school building's responsibility is with
local authorities and multi Academy does
anyone ever say you know what you've
done a good job because everyone else
has sat on there and done nothing no no
signs of that no everybody else was sat
on their asses says the education Chief
who was sat on her ass on holiday in
Spain when the school closures were
ordered
well today a department triumphantly
tweeted most schools unaffected well
that's great news at least we know the
line after the election 40 of Tories
lose their seats most unaffected this
crisis has exposed a phobia that's
gripping politicians around the world
it's the fear of taking responsibility
or saying sorry for anything President
Biden said it was quote not his
responsibility when classified documents
were found piled in his garage next to
his beloved Corvette asked if you take
responsibility of the Taliban
Afghanistan Biden said this don't you
bear some responsibility for the outcome
if the Taliban ends up back in control
and women end up losing no I don't look
do I bear responsibility zero
responsibility and yet it was entirely
your responsibility Mr President
everybody knows what happened over in
Afghanistan the tragic consequences not
least for millions of Afghan women now
being suppressed once again by the
Taliban wolves Boris Johnson infamously
borne their responsibility for literally
anything including an investigation that
was found he lied to Parliament about
lockdown parties and launched a campaign
of abuse against his critics it was all
a terrible Witch Hunt he said Donald
Trump's Godfather of taking their
responsibility a former president would
apparently rather go to jail than admit
he lost an election and a year ago today
Liz trust became prime minister for
disastrous and historically awful 44
days a friend and chance of quasi-cuate
broke Britain with a mini budget that
tanked the pound crashed the markets
blew up mortgages for millions of people
well who bears that responsibility who's
sorry it's pretty clear that most people
are now still paying the price
but apologies there have been none trust
in politics is at an all-time low
because so few politicians just want to
throw their hands up and go it's on me
gov and I'm sorry every leader blames a
guy who messed it up before them and the
one who made it worse afterwards look
it's hard to admit you're wrong I
apparently I've been told that but if
politicians want to rebuild trust it
starts with admitting they broke it in
the first place and occasionally just
saying I sorry it was me